so Cory and I have created several
projects and films together in the past
and we were looking for any reason to
get together and create another one but
to really make this one on a whole other
level and during the process we decided
to adapt Stephen King's Willa and we
came up with five steps to adapting a
book to a film step number one would be
to find a story that speaks to you so I
read will a while ago I just really
responded to the general atmosphere that
Stephen King created with his characters
in the setting and I really just wanted
to take the audience for a ride visually
and emotionally and I felt that Willa
was the best opportunity to do that
really you just have to kind of rely on
your instincts what speaks to you what
do you find yourself thinking about days
and weeks after you've read it as an
actor I really get a feel for for the
characters growth from the first minute
all the way to the end and have that
nice arc of you know him being I'm kind
of like learning a lesson you know and
all of this and and kind of not only
that but putting myself in the shoes of
the character and asking myself
questions of what I would do and how
would I go about doing it and then just
kind of moving forward with with my
co-stars just helping me out and and
driving a really good story forward
especially being an adaptation from
Stephen King I mean you want to
definitely do that justice what I really
hope people take from this is and what I
think would really be cool if people
walked away from seeing this film with a
different perspective on how they view
the world because I actually found
myself doing that after I found myself
kind of living and thinking about the
film and the story and actually
questioning if things around me are
actually real so step number two is what
is your film is it a short does it
feature is it a television series is a
webseries and all of that is going to
affect how you tell your story if you
only have 15 minutes to make a film then
how are you going to structure that and
how are you going to structure your
story into being
fifteen minutes doing a short in
particular is kind of a fun opportunity
because because of the limited time
limit it felt like everything was more
urgent
what do you change keep in to us you
kind of need to do a little bit of all
of that that is going to be the step
that you are working on in
pre-production production and
post-production because I find once you
filter all of your elements through that
entire process then the fat naturally
gets chopped away it it falls off it's
not always about the story in terms of
what you decide to keep change or toss
because sometimes there are elements
that you cannot bring into your story
like if in our case we were able to get
access to a train for our adaptation but
if you don't have the budget to do so or
the ability to gain access to one you
might have to find a different route and
so it's important to see what you have
available to you it's important to look
at your resources look at your crew look
at your cast and realize what you have
to work with and those are going to make
some changes into the story and that's
how you can make it your own
with the Stephen King adaptation yes
that was an ongoing conversation that
sometimes it got controversial because
you you don't want to stray too far away
from the stories of original intent but
you have certain things that come up or
certain ideas that you want to try out
and you know naturally throughout the
whole filming process you you have to
also rely on the rest of your crew and
everyone else whose specialty it is to
handle their departments to let you know
if there is a better option to
accomplish something or a more efficient
way to accomplish something and I feel
like we struck a really good balance
between efficiency and creativity and
establishing the atmosphere that we
wanted and the style that we wanted one
thing that you do have
to just learn to live with this there's
always you can work on something to
death that that's where a hard deadline
comes in handy and especially working
with the big company like the lux I
don't want to I don't want to get on
their nerves and keep giving note after
note basically it's like if it is my
responsibility to make all the best
decisions in the moment and any other
decisions that I think of later it
should be on me to have thought of them
earlier or which probably comes with
experience or maybe they're just not
that important if I didn't think of it
right away
step four is how do you make it your own
that's important because no two
directors are going to make the same
film and with an adaptation it's
important to stay true to the original
story but give it your own voice that's
something you sort of have to figure out
yourself because like I can't tell you
how to make your own only you can really
do that as a director so when I was
making this story my own I really just
tried to interpret how I felt about the
story and what that feeling would look
like if it was a picture again it comes
down that was in part a successful due
to our amazing cinematographer and his
team when it comes to adapting a story I
mean obviously you want to stick with
the source material as much as possible
because that's what made it great to
begin with and that's what made a catch
the attention of the people in charge of
it you know Cory and Barbara when they
are writing it you know Willa stuck out
to them because it's an incredible short
story so obviously they want to stick to
that source material that being said I
mean as filmmakers they also very subtly
and carefully pick moments to kind of
you know surprise the audience at the
same time the things they threw in there
were I think very tastefully done and I
think things that'll really stick with
the audience and make them think and
reflect deeply afterwards just sort of
keep in touch with your feelings like
you have to like it's so hard to
articulate your own feelings at least it
is for me and some people are better at
it than others but in order to be like a
normal person society I think you start
off just
nor your feelings and I just go through
life or whatever but being a director I
think you really sort of have to be in
tune with what you're feeling about the
subject matter you're dealing with or
about the performance you're seeing in
the monitor so step 5 is remember your
audience you need to keep in mind who is
going to be viewing your film they are
going to be fans of the book that you
adapted it from and they want that same
nostalgic feeling that they had when
they originally read it so you know you
have to be true to that you have to be
true to them because as much as you're
making this film for yourself you want
other people to see it right you want
them to either inch it like our intent
it's obviously just to entertain people
and I feel like we knew our audience
because we are a part of that whole
horror community in the Stephen King fan
community we grew up watching these
movies that we grew up reading these
stories so we kept asking ourselves what
would we pay to see horror fans in
particular they can spot fakes pretty
easily they can they I think they have a
good sense of whether you're fraud or
they're they're highly critical but some
of the most diverse fans and and best
fans out there it can work either way
I've seen adaptations work that were
completely different from the book and
I've seen adaptations that stuck to it
religiously and it worked as well so
it's a gamble and you know you don't
really get him in this business to play
it safe right
our film was so special and unique it
was a small independent production over
a hundred crew and we got so much
support from our producers we got
support from IndieGoGo from everyone in
the grip department to catering to craft
services to hair and makeup
electrics we couldn't have done this
without every one of you and
post-production with deluxe as well
we're so fortunate with this film and
everyone who's been a part of it